[Music]
it's super meta this show no it's not a
reality show no it's not a straight
reboot belt well I mean I actually think
that reboots are all the rage right now
and the idea of this show
is that we're taking people behind the
scenes a little bit it's quite a
confusing concept to grasp at first I
understand this is weird to bring the
show back in a different sort of way was
Tori and my idea and then the ball
started rolling and now we're all in it
together I am ready to act summer of my
life well it came from Chris Jenni and I
wanted to work together we were best
friends
ever since the show so we were best
friends for 30 years we were like we
just want to continue to work together
so what can we do then we're like 90210
and really mmm I don't know no one will
ever do that and there were like wasn't
a straight reboot so then we decided
what if we did an entire ensemble cast
playing a heightened version so a
fictitious version of themselves and you
can handle this is the first time an
entire cast has played themselves in an
ensemble so we are playing characters
that have our names our real names
the Shannon in the show oddly enough I
think spells her name with an Ian also
which is great it's me and it's not me
and she's very free-spirited and she's
much more vocal than I would be normally
about where she's at in her life it's
fun it's a lot of fun to play like she's
just a little bit more hippie to be than
I am um it's kind of like assisted
reality that this is a scripted program
so you know there's threads of our real
lives involved I mean it's ions hearings
Brian Green but from there there's
really quite a departure what we loved
is that the entire cast was on board to
kind of poke fun at themselves to go
there to be self-deprecating so that's
what's really cool is everyone's on the
same page going back is chest
are also taking people's perceptions and
images that they think they know about
us and using that to create these
characters and poking fun of it and sort
of flipping it upside down and inviting
people to look at things different but
at the same time familiar I think the
best part is that little element of
really who we are is very free it's
gonna be really interesting for people
to try to pick out what's real and
what's not
and we're gonna be shooting the show
within the show with a remake eventually
so you'll be seeing Kelly and Donna and
David and Brandon as you think you want
to see them but only older so it might
freak people out freak me out do you
know how important this is to me we walk
the line between Beverly Hills 90210 and
BH 902 Oh No there will be some moments
where we do come back to our former
characters when we do cross the line
into the unreal world of Beverly Hills
90210 from the most part in the
inception and through the beginning of
the series it's gonna be us coming
together as friends finding a voice that
we can all speak together and sell a
show and that show will be Beverly Hills
no no to or not I think the 90s is
something that kids nowadays are
dressing like the nineties and I think
it's super cool for the parents because
the parents started turning their kids
on to the original 902 and Oh which
means that now the kids can watch this
one and and and follow it and understand
it and we gained a whole new audience
that's great
we were just like let's do a really
clever show that is funny
kind of taps into the emotional like
it's the ultimate high school reunion
it's like the high school reunion that
won't ever end
[Music]